vous savez ce qu'il faut faire
moi j'ai répété un alors fait voir
attention car deux trois et ensuite de
créer moi un moment l'association un
joli conneries comme ça ça ne veut rien
avec nous et les journaux il deviendra
drôle
posez votre verre attention les petites
mains ah oui et oui c'est terrible échec
bon joueur bon me permettrait d'être
indiscipliné comme je le suis dans
d'autres enceintes l'internât rebelles
bon il a publié un livre
bravo je signale arnaud de montebourg
arnaud montebourg que même les maîtres
du monde le font donc la prochaine fois
arnaud et son golf
bien je ne m'attendais jamais président
là il a bien vu michel aulas fait donc
si vous voulez j'imaginais balladur en
train de faire ça pour coupat attention
les petites mains ah j'oubliais et vous
savez comment il faut faire
montrez-lui gdf
à
et qu'on fait
ces voix là pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu